the world creates 2.5 million terabytes
of data every single day and storing
organizing and analyzing data is
becoming more important than ever
as a data engineer you build the engine
that helps companies manage all of that
data and they are crucial to any
company's data strategy without the
right data infrastructure companies are
under utilizing the data they collect
and waste valuable space
that's why here at udacity we created
this data engineering with microsoft
azure nanodegree program
in this program you will learn how to
design data models build data warehouses
build data lakes and lake house
architecture and create data pipelines
you will also apply these skills
immediately on various hands-on projects
tailored for this program
not only do we provide you with
educational resources and tools you also
gain access to mentors and industry
experts to guide you through your
success
by the end of this course you will be
able to work with large data sets on the
azure platform using azure synapse
analytics azure data bricks and
azure data factory
advance your career in today's
data-driven workforce and sign up now
for udacity's data engineering with
microsoft azure nanodegree program
[Music]
you